do it where is my Juliet so just call
yourself a homie oh no Romeo really dis
even huh
I made my tummy crispy I am better
why do I not why would I kill anyone
well I lost my knife I don't know I
could throw it
hey try get but it's good what's going
on it what are you running I cannot
Aquila Papa Papa is probably fine hey
Popeye are you doing wait so wait so the
gun guy only gets one shot yeah okay
[Laughter]
hell yeah Papa I knew it it's November I
swear I promised I would never lie would
you never lie to me Victor I would never
let me you remember Victor and I'll
consider it
I'm showing but I mean we fix that a
golf Meister might be someone I'm just
an innocent bystander though so I give a
nice look if I know you've apply some
where are you going man where are you
what do you done on a download my knife
gets like possessed when I throw it it's
awesome
minx you do get more bullets by the way
I don't know where you were talking
about that
not that I would know right now because
the cut that I would have the gun nor
anything I just thought I saw you with a
gun or knife or whatever at least I have
a nice shirt you know how do you tell
people that they're innocent I have a
chair - it's my look I have a shot guys
how do I pick it up I have it I have it
to have it like holy [ __ ] mark click
right click right click to throw no huh
do it why are we walking like this what
is the point this is a pretty hot [ __ ]
I wonder what someone else who joins
think that we're doing I'm suspecting
November is the murder no no he's in
here I swear using no Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
a Dahlia at Omni SEC he hates them it's
got a gun I've come to charm every when
I want you to look at my body and tell
me what you think you're like an old man
model so you are an old man in a pink
shirt yet like if Tony Soprano when I am
not at all me I'm a crab
where's the gun I can only walk sideways
come Alfa has begun because I might be
fine do you think I'm the murderer kill
me then well I can't face don't you obey
don't you just die I swear to God Papa
you're not even a woman dad come here
hey come here come here come here come
here
I said you like 10 times how are you
even moving come here come here come
here
CAPA take the gun you want the gun huh
you want the gun
you want that thing over there take it
hey stop your tits off
Oh strafe skills huh I play like games
[Laughter]
that's why they were like they don't
know how to spell they were trying to
normal I do what Bravo
what are you trying to do Bravo I'm just
gonna turn around and if someone happen
to stab them in the back you know I was
thinking one second what the hell
what's the merderet thanks mark I could
have lived you know to be sure when he
pulled out the knife I still wasn't
hundred you never know maybe just want
to cut his bread or something I don't
know hey hey crap how you doing what's
on my head I am I am you on your
and we are collabs yes what are you
doing I am the cave
are you a crab Miko Nick okay I'm
claiming this crate this is my crate but
then what would you do if I step on top
of the kite huh your clay what
slap me please sir I'm here with my
flashlight that's the best I can do
sounds really spooky also my value all
right this is our codes if Zulu comes
here we're gonna show you who has a gun
oh there's two Zulus I don't have a gun
how do you shoot people
it's x-ray someone has a gun and he's
not telling about it oh no oh no hey you
want that gun over there them skills to
the left Kayla Kayla track oh I saw
who's the killer
Oh Oh what help Oh God I even know I was
the murderer what the [ __ ] I forgot
about it I got so distracted with all
their commands I forgot what I was doing
I see a guy holding a knife oh you don't
oh you know what are you doing with that
knife why am i following a guy with a
knife no God make sure I got a 44 that
for the body where's the body
oh the building huh it's fine hey how
are you echo I have whiskey hi hi wait
Kenny can you go here in the center what
just happened I don't understand oh no I
hurt mark I heard you yell I understand
what happened
I don't know what happened yeah our
beauty is innocent I will go by that oh
god damn it what did I do to make you
love me I can sprint holy [ __ ] oh I got
someone into Ted yeah you all claimed it
it wasn't my fault you pressured me very
good
never hit me I'm an impenetrable wall a
full fruit manliness